the problem in afghanistan was because
of foreigners now the biggest goal is
achieved and us haqqani tells us from
his new accommodation in a leafy suburb
in western kabul
here he is a diplomat talking with
former government leaders to encourage
them to join a new taliban government
still he's wanted by the us which calls
him a terrorist and is also under un
sanctions the taliban is still
organizing the government but what are
the aims of the government
overall and to maintain and be faithful
to what we were fighting for to serve
the afghan people and to serve islam
the people who were working towards this
goal have been fighting for 20 years
have given their lives lost family
members and have been locked inside
jails hikani himself was imprisoned for
five years and sentenced to death he was
released two years ago to accelerate
stalled peace talks with the us in qatar
do you know what position you will have
in government
due to every human having weaknesses i
question my ability but we have our
elders orders and we have to do what
they tell us according to our ideology
but my personal desire is to finish my
education live freely and help other
muslims
the haqqani network was started by his
father jalaluddin and has since folded
into the taliban it's been responsible
for some of the worst attacks in
afghanistan in recent years his uncle
halil now leads security operations in
kabul his brother surajudeen is the
taliban's deputy leader
often when governments come into power
there are internal divisions is the
taliban unified or are there divisions
we took control of kabul and other
provinces peacefully and reduce the
damage to infrastructure and bloodshed
this shows our unity and alliance
we hope that we will prosper and pray
that we never desire designations power
and wealth
we've seen the images of people running
to the airport they say they're
terrified they're scared of the taliban
is it warranted and what can you do to
reassure them
we've implemented a ceasefire now when
they say they're scared of the taliban
it's just an excuse in reality the
americans have created this issue to
degrade our nation they want to show a
comparison of vietnamese hanging on to
u.s helicopters
after thursday's attack there's been a
lot of concern about isil in afghanistan
what is the taliban strategy to counter
isil
we fought with the world empty handed
and came this far we can get rid of such
a group like we have in the past this is
not something to be stressed about
[Music]
and yet many afghans are many feel
threatened not just by isil but by the
taliban not knowing what to expect from
the group 20 years since it was last in
power
charlotte ballas al jazeera kabul